et ce matin à montigny le bretonneux la
nouvelle résidence du vélodrome pour
jeunes travailleurs a été inauguré le
montant de la réalisation de l'opération
réalisée par le bailleur osica s'élève à
12 millions huit cent quarante mille
euros avec la participation de l'état du
conseil régional et départemental mais
aussi de la caf
un bâtiment à l'architecturé
contemporaine comme vous pouvez le voir
sur les images qui comprend dix
logements accessibles aux personnes à
mobilité réduite les 183 logements
individuels de la résidence qui est
gérée par l'association pro logement des
jeunes travailleurs sont déjà pourvus
les précisions au micro de william el
est ce que je vois c'est que ça
fonctionne à 100 % le taux d'occupation
est donc et à 100 morceaux où il ya 50
23 place il ya plus de 1000 demandes qui
ont été faites donc on voit bien qu'il y
avait un besoin
cinquante ans de vie de compte 135 mille
emplois de nombreuses entreprises dont
nous faisons le lien nous aujourd'hui
entre notre diversité de grandes écoles
nos jeunes du territoire
c'est une résidence qui s'adresse aux
jeunes travailleurs donc des jeunes de
18 à 26 ans à l'entrée des jeunes qui
sont en activité qui vont débuter une
activité professionnelle qui sont en
contrat d'apprentissage de
professionnalisation sur 2015 nous avons
accueilli nous avons traité plus de 1000
candidatures et nous avons accueilli 246
jeunes pour 183 places
le loyer est de 410 euros pour les
petites studette et nous avons des
studios qui sont à 506 euros
le studio